oui c'est un bon élève d'un tribunal qui
marche bien qu'ils jugent chaque année
plus d'affaires qu'il n'en reçoit est
donc réduit son stock est donc réduit
les délais de jugement il est bien gérée
et d'ailleurs je voulais vous dire très
fermement
il restera à besançon aucun projet de le
déplacer
aucun projet de changer son ressort il
restera tel qu'il est sans changement et
je pense que ça fasse sur à tous ceux
qui aiment avoir recours tribunal
administratif de besançon
vous êtes venu présenter les recours
citoyens comment ça marche
et quel est son objectif l'objectif
c'est de permettre à tous ceux qui ne
sont pas représentés par un avocat mais
aussi aux petites communes aux
associations de pouvoir saisir le juge
administratif en ligne aujourd'hui c'est
possible et même obligatoire si vous
êtes défendu par un avocat ou si c'est
l'état ou une grande collectivité qui
est en défense mais nous voulons
aujourd'hui ouvrir les facilités de la
justice en ligne à tout à chacun à
chaque citoyen qu'ils soient défendus
par un avocat ou pas ça veut dire que
monsieur x ou monsieur y madame y
qui veut saisir le tribunal
administratif pourra le faire de chez
lui de chez n 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 sans avoir à se déplacer pour a
envoyé par finalement internet sa
requête toutes les pièces qu'elle veut
joindre à sa requête
elle sera informé en ligne du
déroulement de la procédure et recevra
in fine et le jugement en ligne ça veut
dire plus de délai morts la capacité de
savoir à tout moment où en est cette
affaire sans papiers sans se déplacer
sans avoir besoin de téléphoner 35% des
affaires traitées ici au tribunal
administratif de besançon concernent des
étrangers
c'est une activité importante également
dans tous les tribunaux administratifs
oui quoi dans tous les tribunaux
administratifs et même dans une
proportion souvent plus importante qu'à
besançon bien ça reflète à la fois la
pression migratoire qui s'est accéléré
il y a plusieurs années et puis aussi la
volonté du gouvernement par
l'intermédiaire des préfets et bien
d'exécuter les arrêtés de reconduite à
la frontière
quand un certain nombre d'étrangers
demande le statut de réfugié et qu'il ne
leur est pas accordée ou séjournent sans
autorisation sur notre territoire
ils font souvent l'objet d' obligation
de quitter le territoire et ce sont ces
injonctions de quitter le territoire qui
sont attaqués devant le juge
administratif dans des proportions
importantes et c'est normal parce que
c'est important humainement pour ces
étrangers qui sont souvent conseillé et
aidé et donc on se tourne vers le juge
administratif pour savoir si ces arrêtés
sont légaux ou pas ce chiffre est-il en
augmentation par rapport à l'année
dernière
et quelle comparaison peut-on établir
avec les autres tribunaux administratifs
de france cette proportion augmente
partout devant les tribunaux
administratifs
en 2018 le nombre d'affaires entrées a
augmenté de 7 et demi pour cent et dans
ses sets et demi pour cent
quatre-vingt-dix pour cent de
l'augmentation est due au contentieux
des étrangers donc c'est une réalité
dans toute la france y compris à
besançon même si la hausse est moins
forte puisque à besançon le nombre
d'affaires entrées n'a augmenté que de 4
et demi pour cent